I'm curious now on your thoughts on
speaker McCarthy he gets elected he's uh
you know he removes Schiff and um
swallow well from the intelligence
committee which I agree with I I
actually agree with your initial
argument on ilhan Omar that removing her
simply because she said things you don't
like doesn't seem to make sense but uh
how did you end up going on you you
ended up voting for her removal
yeah I did I didn't feel good about it
to be honest with you I uh believed that
had ilhan Omar not voted to remove
Marjorie teller green and Paul gosar
from their committees that she would
have found a great deal more support uh
I I think that was ultimately the
decision maker not just for me but
probably for a handful of members that
you know if you're going to adopt this
terrible Paradigm and then you're not
willing to live by it that's actually
the swamp that's actually what we see
too often here and that hypocrisy had to
be dealt with in some way but here's
what I know
if the normal rhythm of this place is
that every time power changes hands you
got to go nuke some of the loud people
on the other side who you don't agree
with it will actually be Lauren bobert
and Anna Paulina Luna and Matt Gates who
will get nuke next we have to understand
that and so I hope this ends It
ultimately what got me there look
McCarthy and Hakeem Jeffries both agreed
this has to end and I hope it ends at at
this standpoint the the Schiff and
swallow thing is very different because
they can be judged based on their acts
they took actions that hurt our country
by lying about intelligence I do not
believe that Congressman Omar did that I
think she had made comments that upset
the various groups of people and that
that achieved a critical mass at some
point but sometimes we've got to listen
to the dissidents right sometimes we
have to be thoughtful and introspective
and reflective about what people say who
don't always align with the traditional
dogma of this place I I also too though
think that representative Perry brought
a great perspective which is ultimately
why I voted the way that I did which was
you know you have to be careful on the
speech aspect right because next cycle
if we don't have the gavel ultimately
they might say that something that we
said was offensive and wrong and try to
remove us from committees um so do be
clear she saw in committees but she also
did something that is really bad
especially when you're on Foreign
Affairs and that is that she all getting
inside
um basically had engaged in Immigration
fraud and so I think that when people
are being looked at for their committees
what they bring to the table I think
that that's an important note yeah but
by what standard okay by what standard
what what we because there were some
news articles we automatically assume
that that's the truth I mean there were
a lot of news articles about me that
were false right and so I I have a
higher standard for due process than
that we have an Ethics Committee and we
have an ethics rule that says that if
you bring discredit on the house by your
actions that then you can be expelled
from this institution and that we are
ultimately the Arbiters of our own
membership and so I don't love of the
fact that we removed somebody without
that due process I I do believe that a
number of us got speaker McCarthy to
agree that in the future there has to be
some ability for people to appeal and
and have a potential removal examine
more thoroughly but you know there were
a lot of Republicans who were waving
their pom-poms about that vote I cast
the vote I do believe on committee
membership the speaker deserves
deference but if this becomes a
situation where we cancel people in the
Congress on committees based on their
perspective on certain things that don't
align with the traditional Dogma then
I'm probably the next one on The
Chopping Block so I got a question for
both of you uh how would you rate
speaker McCarthy's performance thus far
I would give speaker McCarthy an a I
would and he has kept his commitments he
has reaffirmed his commitments I am
eager to get the 14 000 hours of January
6 footage out and if you had been in
some of the depositions I've been in
these last few days with FBI officials
getting that information out is
critically important our weaponization
subcommittee has already begun the
process of collecting documents and
interviewing whistleblowers and
I I am deeply concerned about the extent
to which that undercover Federal
officers and confidential informants
that were working for the federal
government could have animated some of
the criminal Acuity of that day
um also too for those who are looking
and watching this right now I actually
spoke to speaker McCarthy's office and
he said that if you do have a case and
that you feel that footage might
actually help your case to prove that
you are innocent that they will actually
work to get that footage to you so to
contact your member of Congress and then
they can work to do that so I think that
for people watching obviously there are
many different circumstances and so
people deserve to write have the right
to defend themselves and they deserve
the right to access to that footage and
they have that now well just look at the
today today we passed a Thomas Massey
bill that carried with it a Lauren
bobert substantive Amendment this is the
type of stuff that you would not have
seen in a traditional Congress where the
people who have access to the floor and
the amendatory process are those who are
blessed by the lobbyists and speaker
McCarthy to his great credit was willing
to give the power back to the members
and a meritocracy develops as a
consequence of that that you don't get
when it's just about who writes the
checks
so does it feel like at least for you
guys the people are starting to win back
control
yeah I mean listen think about just that
question from one of the last questions
you asked me when I was on your program
you said Gates how worried are you about
retribution
that was yours your your belief was that
what we the the force that we had
brought on this place would result in us
being punished and instead it's our
amendments our bills our ideas that are
driving the discussion and you know what
we're not going to win them all we're
gonna get beat sometimes on the floor on
the ideas we present like when Marjory
Taylor green put an idea up to limit the
president's ability to just issue an
emergency over everything and everything
that lost but we're actually willing to
take votes on amendments that lose and I
think that that brings the American
people into the discussion in a far more
fruitful way what about uh what's up
with that demolishing the IRS
well I believe we should have the fair
tax I believe the American people should
be able to choose how much taxes they
pay based on their consumption and if
you want to go buy a Lamborghini or some
like crazy expensive skateboard that
some dude you know makes in his garage
then all the better but then you can pay
the taxes on that and what frustrates us
is that oftentimes we're just funding
the bureaucracy it's not even like we're
extracting money from the American
people to go to their needs we're
extracting it to fund a system that
picks winners and losers and the
powerful and the elite and the connected
get get access to that system so so
let's uh I'll give you a hypothetical if
um we could probably very difficult to
do but let's say we were able to isolate
specifically bloated bureaucracy
spending if we could take all of that
money and apply it to Health Care
government spending that money instead
on helping people with Health Care would
you be in favor of that well I I
absolutely would but but let's look at
the VA which is something that Anna and
I have talked about at Great length not
just in the policy space but as it
literally relates to you know our our
families and the people we love if we
abolished the VA and gave every veteran
a card that allowed them to get fee for
service at any health care provider that
they walked into in this country and if
you want to provide Health Care in this
country you better be willing to provide
it for to a veteran for the amount that
we would pay for it at that rate then
you could eliminate the bureaucracy and
you could spend all the money that is
appropriate to that bureaucracy actually
on health care for veterans yeah if I if
that was an option today I guarantee
most vets would go that route and one of
the most frustrating things is that
especially during what happened with
covid because of the bureaucracy a lot
of veterans that did need help
especially that had PTSD that needed to
talk to doctors weren't getting the help
that they needed but but if we're gonna
do Universal Health Care which is the
essence of your question
in exchange for bureaucratic inertia and
bureaucratic waste there's no more
fruitful space than the VA and no more
meritorious space
yeah I mean he he nailed it again
systems like the VA mind you service
members do essentially pay into that and
so that's a friendly reminder to people
a lot of people say well the military
has socialized health care but we are
literally paying back into that system
so for me from that perspective I mean
there's so much broken with the VA
president Trump did a lot of good but
there's still so much that needs to be
fixed with it and so I just anyone that
ever advocates for socialized medicine
I'm like you guys have no idea what
you're starting oh yeah I'm I'm also
very glad that this time I get to talk
to you my voice actually works I was
like bad things
the magic of the last episode was that
you couldn't talk and that Ian was
giving us brilliant take after brilliant
take
surge even got in the action
let's say this here we are because I
want to ask you and both you guys really
what do you guys think about like
setting up an application or an app or
something where people could allocate a
portion of their taxes like a sliding
thing where you're like okay first of
all it's like a well I'll say Tinder
like you swipe right if you like this
this idea they want to build a fountain
on main street and then you go into your
little thing you can slide I want to put
three percent of my discretionary tax
money towards the fountain and this and
that and then you've got like you have
to do 10 minimum for the police 10 for
the fire department 30 for black budget
military because what the heck you know
you get you get some control you get
some control over your tax where you put
your taxes and then maybe the system can
sort itself out
yeah I uh I think that that would
convert our
Republic to a direct democracy right and
that's what you're talking about you're
talking about direct Democratic inputs
to the Appropriations process and
I don't know I I it's crowdsourcing the
Appropriations process we had to look
we're just trying to crowdsource the
Appropriations process among the elected
representatives and we about had to burn
this place to the ground
extortionist terrorists I mean
everything yeah but I uh you know I I'd
have to think about that thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time